[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here
at the i go live apps launch event and i
gotta tell you it was a night of
Kardashian X's Lamar Odom Tyga blac
Chyna we talked to them all you look
great
let me just ask you you know you have
you been through a lot lately but how
are you doing I'm doing good I'm doing
good I'm just feeling blessed right now
tell me about this dress what makes you
wear a dress you know I had to like she
come out show out you know
I'm so excited though to be here really
yeah and how are little King and little
dream we love watching you raise them oh
my god like they're amazing yeah
yes they're doing well you're doing well
fishing I guess here tonight but he told
me you guys are good good to see him
tonight ya know for sure we're good we
have we have a baby together you know
[Music]
with the Kardashians how is your
relationship with the family I'm good
yeah what's next for you just being
positive and you know working on my
brand and last and eighty eight thing
that's really all I can do right now and
being a good mother of course I was
black trying to do it right now in one
word fantastic
[Music]
you